[Music]
so we're on Good Morning America today
yes yeah what was going on
so this so I was in this documentary
called the problem with Appu right which
basically breaks down the problem of the
character Appu on the system yeah and
how it's offensive and stereotypical and
how for decades this guy who's a friend
of mine now Hank Azaria a white man
right has been voicing an Indian care
forever he's yeah for years how many
episodes is up who better I don't know
yeah I don't know let's say at least a
hundred right in some capacity and the
character for me growing up in this
country in 1988 when the Simpsons
dropped Appu is the only character of
Indian descent that the American
populace hat was exposed to right right
so if you are I mean rightfully so
people in India are ignorant to people
in Iowa so it's not like some what's
nuts to a street but like if you are in
an Indian American growing up in this
country and all your classmates the only
reference point they have for somebody
that looks like you is a poo from The
Simpsons then all of a sudden you become
a slushie boy you become 7-eleven clerk
you become an offensive and inaccurate
accent and that's who you are and that's
your identity mm-hmm no I'd never watch
The Simpsons so when people started
calling me slushy boy I was like I don't
get the joke you seem like an idiot like
what what are you talking about but you
know then you're introduced to the show
and you're like oh this guy's gonna be
the bane of my existence until people
grow up enough to understand humanity as
a whole right as opposed to these
stereotypical little boxes that we
operate in when we're kids and even at
that time I'm sure their parents and
adults didn't know as much as they do
now so anyway but this whole thing like
blew up all of a sudden like yes there
was an article being written or what
happened like why do things suddenly
become a controversy a good friend of
mine this comedian his name is Hari
Kondabolu he made a documentary called
the problem with Appu which aired on
truTV in November and we did a talk back
in New York and Whoopi Goldberg was
there
which was like I got to sit next to
Whoopi and she hugged me it was so cool
kiss me on the cheek
oh man we were like in front all these
people and I was like I would be she was
like hug and kiss me now let's give him
a show and I was like okay coo coo coo
coo coo I think I remember when you
shared that on Instagram yeah what's
going on why is he with Whoopi Goldberg
so stoked man she gave me real life
advice I mean I'll get to that but the
documentary just breaks down the
systemic racism specifically within the
South Asian country that's that's been
done in American cinema like brown faced
and Peter Sellers that movie and all of
Indiana Jones and the Temple of Doom
just how we've been underrepresented and
misrepresented for several years and up
who the character about who being the
entry point into that conversation right
now a lot of people take things at face
value so they're just like you're just
mad at a poo and it's like no we're
trying to make a larger point here that
was her ease goal so the last episode of
The Simpsons addressed this hari
Kondabolu issue and Lisa and Marge are
sitting and Lisa's like you know she
addresses the camera and she goes you
know sometimes things that used to be an
offensive are now offensive and there's
just nothing we can do about it and then
it pans over to a picture of a poo with
a quote that says don't have a cow man
which is what it is and then the
Simpsons basically goes we'll get to it
when we want to so they had an
opportunity to address the situation in
a careful and thoughtful manner and
these a bunch of Harvard writers or
whoever's writing over at The Simpsons I
think I play basketball with one of them
and he definitely didn't go to Harvard
but they they were pretty careless and
it was sort of slippin about the whole
thing yeah and so they copped out right
so it created this big hullabaloo and
the only reason The Simpsons is getting
this cultural relevancy again because as
we know any consumer of pop culture
knows they haven't been a part of it for
several years but this documentary is
now shedding light on them so they're
getting publicity because of us
basically and they had an opportunity to
kind of say something and yet like like
South Park would have taken that
opportunity and and sort of created
something very insightful out of it I
feel like yeah I deal
I would think so as well I mean they've
consistently hit controversial topics
out of the park like and they've done it
really well and honestly and I think
that's what's important you know they're
also not sitting in an amusement park
industry like The Simpsons is a billion
dollar corporation like forget a
creative expression it is a corporation
like Walmart or Target or whatever
Viacom it's it's like any of those but
so this episode came out and there was
outcry and I actually played a character
on The Simpsons I played up whose nephew
on the show and that episode which aired
a couple years ago in 2016 was meant to
draw some attention towards the
stereotypical nature of apu's character
but they copped out in that episode as
well and my nephew goes you're a
stereotype you're a Temple of Doom guy
and then up who's like well you're a
hipster and essentially he wins the
stereotype argument by calling my
character a hipster uh-huh he's like
you're just a young hipster and
everyone's like yeah like the racist
stereotypical trope is still allowed
because hipsters suck right and because
of that they think that I've got some
sort of expert opinion on this stuff
because you played up news yeah yeah
well in your you're Indian you're an
Indian actor right you're part of this
community and you were friends with a
filmmaker who made a documentary correct
so when you go on Good Morning America I
mean what are they asking you and what
did you what did you say you know it
just happened it was a 20 minute
interview that ended up being one line
yet I use always like end the line that
that I you that I said was like you know
it was a cop out they were the actual
quote from the show is things that used
to be inoffensive are now offensive when
in point of fact in 1988 or 89 whenever
the simpsons was created when the app
crew character was born it was offensive
then like that's the part you don't
realize is that when you decided to
create this character you were already
creating a problem
well it's almost I mean it's really more
offensive right it's almost like an
answer my my kind of thing because there
was no other counterpoint to it there
wasn't like a Kumail Nanjiani or there
weren't like a whole bunch of other
people
interesting things yeah on screen at
that time of Indian descent now you know
there's there's more and more people
exactly great super cool to see that but
when it's the only example in media then
it becomes this trope that yeah I would
imagine you know is painful for kids
like yourself who have to grow up on the
receiving end of you know jokes about it
but also speaks to a larger issue about
our myopic you know kind of blind spot
about race in America a hundred percent
and that's the thing when people are
like well what are you gonna do with the
app who character now it's like I don't
give a [ __ ] like up who is a cartoon in
1988 he had power then the Simpsons has
got a core fanbase they are no longer
culturally relevant you know who is
culturally relevant as he's Ansari who
just won a Golden Globe Kumail Nanjiani
who just got nominated for an Oscar
Mindy who just did a movie with Oprah
like Riz Ahmed who won an Emmy like the
list goes on and on hari Kondabolu who's
got a Netflix special like you know I'm
working every now and then as well like
I'm working all the time yeah you know
like I mean even in comparison to like a
year ago like your career is on this
crazy trajectory all of a sudden it's um
it's sometime you know my team or my
friend Nick Collins who's also my agent
he just said you know sometimes things
click and you can actually hear it click
and he was like somewhere around like
last October like I just heard a click
right and from then it's been like a
pretty it's been blessing you know what
it is like you work hard you're under
the radar you're just started chipping
away drop in the it's the 10 year
overnight you know overnight success
story yeah but it's like every day it's
like rich roll anybody who follows you
on Instagram or knows what you do every
day it's those hand paddles right clap
and then one day someone's like whoa
hand paddles that's a great idea what
like that that's a new thing we know
it's so funny about the hand paddle now
like people mock me or they do it
themselves and then they tag me in it
and then I give them a grade on how well
they execute upon that dude that is my
that is such a soothing sound to me of
two hand paddles I didn't know what they
were yeah I was like what are those
things what are you doing
yeah I thought you were they were like
foot things and you run in the water
right I thought it was like some Navy
SEAL training that you've learned in
like Galapagos or whatever I wish that
would be a much better story now and
pathways are good speaking of like you
know lack of familiarity I mean I've
known you for a number of years but I
think you know for awhile like we have
mutual friends and I was kind of around
you and I knew like oh this guy's like
he's like an actor or something I don't
really know what when vice versa I knew
like oh he was in barbershop or
something like that yeah but then I was
listening to a radio lab podcast I'm
just like a geeky science podcast and it
was an episode about like this beetle I
can't even remember exactly but it was
like we went down the rabbit hole about
a beetle and then they kind of the whole
episode culminates with this like little
rap that lin-manuel Miranda yeah and
yourself and who's the other guy like
the two of us is just the two of ya yeah
yeah we did it and there's like and like
the hosts are like yeah it's gonna be
lin-manuel Miranda and Karsh I'm glued a
car on boot car that's how you say it
right yeah because I was like an bleep
boot Karsch
like is that the same dude like I go
there can't be another dude named Kart
and I was like oh my god and I heard you
do this wrap with lin-manuel Miranda
yeah like wow that dudes talented like
that was super cool
that's a deep cut that was a Valentine's
Day episode of radio a while ago yeah
and Lin and I just basically sent like
bootleg Garage Band vocals back and
forth to each other for like 72 hours
and came up with that which is great you
know they just approach you like can you
do a rap song about a Beatle like yeah
the weirdest thing Tommy Cal who's kind
of like the glue between all these guys
that I'll introduce you to I'm sure
during the course of this conversation
came to us and it sort of started where
you you know Google zeitgeist yeah
they've got huh sort of whatever summer
camp it feel it's like a TED conference
for like super amazing people
yeah like Bill Clinton speaks spoke
there when we were there so basically
our group freestyle Love Supreme
performed a Google zeitgeist and what
year was that that was 2000 and I wasn't
it's a while ago though yeah it was it
was 2012 or 2013 uh-huh and they at the
radio lab guy whose name is escaping me
right now
like jad album rod or something like
that sure yeah he he I guess reached out
and was like we have this fun idea and
we think Linn and you know whoever else
would be great for it and right Tommy
put it in my lap and I was able to
execute so we had a great time and
freestyle Love Supreme
is this collective of like super
talented dudes I mean it's incredible
what the men in this group have done of
essentially like improvisational rappers
so it is long-form improv we have games
that are songs subject based songs and
then we just freestyle rap for the
entire show it's about an hour long and
I've been in that group for 15 years the
member of that group oh yeah I had the
UM a camera so I can show you we all
have this tattoo oh this is the
freestyle Love Supreme inside of Mike
yeah and then the nyancy is my moniker
of course the incredible incendiary
incapacitated incorrigible incredible so
essentially it's like improv rap right
like you're just completely coming up on
the fly with it's freestyle rap so the
members of the group just to just to
brag literally no other reason just to
get my validation from the your hundreds
of millions of listeners wish go ahead
shout out to Iceland
it's a Christopher Jackson who played
George Washington in the Broadway
musical Hamilton about me Diggs who won
a Tony Award for Thomas Jefferson and
Lafayette in the Broadway musical
Hamilton James Monroe I go hard Tony
Award winner for playing the genie in
Aladdin and currently playing Jefferson
and Lafayette in Hamilton
Anthony Vernon see Ali who is runs the
speechless improv program and also the
freestyle Love Supreme School he's one
of our de facto leaders bill Sherman who
is an Oscar away from getting that he
got he is the music director process
Street crew shockwave Sullivan from The
Electric Company beatbox or vocal
performer Arthur Lewis incredible hermit
and also magical musical mind
lin-manuel Miranda who is nobody right
no nobody's ever heard of it yeah
alright Lin Lin and then me I think
that's the whole crew and we have a
couple alternates but I think that's the
core crew right there huh and so you
guys do you guys all get together as a
group from time to time or house yeah
what happens is once a year all the
stars align I mean la Anthony's in San
Francisco Lin is all over the world all
the time although he currently has
shingles which is amazing because two
weeks ago I got adult chickenpox and now
we're both I can't I know I couldn't
believe you got chicken pox shingles
that's all you and I are in constant
synergy it's strange but um we get
together maybe once a year now and it's
a sold-out show within five minutes it's
always been a sold-out show some 15
years ago when I was a 21 year old kid
being introduced to the group and
showing up at a 150 seat theater and
being like whoa
this is what a packed house feels like
in New York because I'm playing to like
my girlfriend and my friend's girlfriend
and nobody yet right and it was such a
trip and the thing about freestyle Love
Supreme is it's freestyle rapping just
to like speak about it quickly I come
from like a battle rap background so
when I met the guys I was you've seen
the movie eight months of course I was
doing eight mile raps which is
essentially can we curse on this black
hair of course which is essentially dick
swinging right it's an ego it's an
expression of all of the fantasies of
one's ego and aggressive masculine hyper
raw and and very much about very
narcissistic right very much about well
it's alpha right you're trying to take
the other guy so it's like yeah I'll be
spinning and ripping and it's the Indian
revenues engine and I'm better than
anyone getting attention like dispensing
these rhythms uh suspending your
disbelief you smell like a queef I mean
I would never say that but like like you
know I'll bury you I'll carry you this
is a you know a dividend mean
mean-spirited mmm-hmm so I auditioned
for the group and like I don't the
reasoning was that Lynne needed a
replacement because he was going to do
in the heights this was years ago way
before Hamilton Oh way before Hamilton
was ever an apple and anyone's I I
suppose and so I joined the group and
Lynne and I wrapped together and I
wrapped with the guys and it was sort of
instant like okay cool like these people
do what I do I didn't I didn't know
people like me existed and vice versa
and would you like a freshman at NYU
then or how I was graduating early from
NYU I was 20 years old so I was
finishing school I graduated a semester
early he did a year a good Indian boy
yeah right uh-huh year early technically
but I had to do a little experimental
theater program just to see if I if I
could get a little bit more juice out of
the educational experience
turns out no no well let's take it back
I mean I have a pretty good sense of of
you know the sort of time in place in
which you grew up because I'm from
Maryland as well whereabouts
Bethesda you went to bcc I would have
gone to Whitman I went to a private high
school I was well friends I went to
Landon oh I wish I'd gonna sit so I went
to one place but you went to whoot and I
friends I went to wooed and I swam with
kids that went to Wooten I been to whoo
Dan I know that high school yeah and I I
know the kind of surrounding area there
so I have a mental picture of where you
grew up
White Flint Mall thank you oh that was
like my jam well I would train every
morning swimming at you know which you
know Georgetown Prep on Rockville Pike
Mike clutter at my club rented that pool
there so I would go I would go there
every morning and I had like 5 a.m. some
practice there and White Flint mall is
like just down the street is this still
there oh yeah dude when that cheesecake
factory opened up I was like it was
pandemonium and then it would be like
you go to Cheesecake Factory and like
all the the roll over whoever couldn't
get in the Cheesecake Factory would be
at PF Changs all sad about eating their
dumplings and sat a PF Changs again we
missed out on Cheesecake Factory that's
crazy man well just to date myself you
know I remember one white when whitefly
Mall opened like when it
built oh sure what year were you born
I'm 83 yeah so I was swimming at I was
training at Georgetown Prep when you
were born no way cuz like well I
graduated high school in 85
oh really or two when I went to college
Wow yeah so that's that's the
differential here so that's why I was
like wow it's still there
like cuz I I go way back I thought you
are so much younger than now dude
alright so you're growing up out
Rockville way pretty much Yeah right
there
and so do you are you like like so when
do you get into like the battle rap are
you like breakdancing like I just
picture you being like I picture you in
high school and correct me if this is
wrong because his total projection your
you seem like the kind of kid who you're
not gonna be like wearing a leather
jacket and being like the super varsity
you know alpha athlete dude but you're
funny and you're the kind of kid who
like knows how to make friends so you
were somebody who could like gravitate
between all the cliques and like be
friends with everybody
yeah it's not a projection it's pretty
close to reality yeah I was uh just
gregarious I was the type of that was
the dude who would like run down the
halls singing songs and just like
high-fiving everyone and mm-hmm I took
pride in that everyone knew who I was
right it was one of those things where
it's like validation by committee like
please if I know everyone then there's
meaning in my life and there was real
joy in it like I don't you know I was I
really wanted to play basketball and
then freshman year I didn't make the
team I went to see the high school
musical that year and I was like oh ha I
could definitely do this like this is
something I could do really well or at
least I thought I could and then the
next year I started doing theater and I
fell in love with the community and the
people and the the friendship I had
moved in the middle of eighth grade to
Montgomery County from Howard County
uh-huh so everyone at that age you're
like 12 years old you're like going into
high school and you're all clicked up
that was pretty lonely for the first
year but when I found that theater
community I was really I really got that
that I had something special to offer
people you know and I did all the dance
competitions and like yeah I definitely
was a popper and Locker and like we won
every year I mean my buddy Camby Cathy
Xie we were the
of comedy and skill we weren't the best
by any means but your entry point wasn't
like comedy per se it was more like
theater song and song dance like that it
was it was comedy for it wasn't stand-up
but it was comedic acting so what I
would do and I can't believe my teachers
let me do it like I can't believe the
directors let me do it like we'd have
this play we'd have like a Shakespeare
play and then I would just improvise on
stage every night I would just I mean I
would stay within the boundaries of that
Shakespeare play but other plays I did I
would just improvise I would come up
with whole bits onstage in front of the
audience in front of nine nine hundred
to a thousand people just go off script
on Shakespeare off script yeah I'm just
like the one thing no improv I'm bugging
out like well in between the lines like
I do the shakes iambic pentameter bro I
would do like the iambic container I
would do the verse and then in between I
would just do whatever the hell I wanted
uh-huh and the audience responded and
that drug of right laughter do you know
the joy I had this image in my head of a
woman sitting in like the third or
fourth row miserable look on her face
and halfway through the first scene she
starts to smile and she starts to look
happy like I'm a bad actor at this age I
still am a bad actor in the sense that
like as I'm acting I'm totally looking
at the audience if I'm in a play not in
a little bit I'm like hey like smiley
and he said you guys like me like me
it's like it's one of those things were
you know when I see actors who immerse
themselves in a role like a Daniel
day-lewis who's like I am Abraham
Lincoln I don't think I could ever do
that because I'm like hey guys are we
good just connecting is this working for
you I can't get it so my Abraham Lincoln
as a total like a side tangent I saw in
your IMDB you did a short film called
Real Housewives of Shakespeare oh yeah
just like me laughs that was my I didn't
see it but no that's a hilarious title
yeah it was in my friend Jamie King a
very very good friend of mine and
writing partner broke this whole thing
for his thesis at Loyola Marymount grad
school and made this whole show in verse
and it's the real housewives but with
all the Shakespeare
Shakespeare ladies and I played puck in
that and puck was like a you know like a
rapper or some sort of like public
figure yeah it was one of those things
where we like we're in a hotel for like
15 hours and I was like Jamie I love you
bro and he knows this cuz I said it to
him I was like I'm never doing this for
you again we're not doing this again
well back to this validation thing sort
of a trope like Oh performing arts
theater you know actor singer dancer
dude like you know feeds off validation
like of course but you know I see you
know you share your share on Instagram
like when you go home and you visit your
parents or when they visit you like your
parents seem super supportive yeah it's
not like oh I didn't get it at home so I
had to get it somewhere else I think
that that is indicative of where we are
now in our relationship my parents and I
right so that has you put him through it
yeah you know yeah I I was not the most
present or positive son and they'll
disagree because they'll be like that
means we weren't good parents but they
were and they were supportive and they
tried and they were loving but they were
also talking about two people who at the
age of 28 moved to a new country with
very little money they moved to
Baltimore Maryland which is not the
nicest city at the time in 1980 in the
United States of America and they worked
on post doctorate salaries which was
maybe 10 to 15,000 a year for the first
month the processing system thought that
they both were one person because they
shared the last name so they were
working off for one check and they move
into a brand-new country they have a
child who's boisterous loud energetic
out-of-control very happy and they have
to raise this new human as an American
in a country that they are just
beginning to understand so so many of
the experiences that I had at a chat as
a child they had no reference point for
so when I'm 12 or 13 and I'm like yellow
I got to have a girlfriend everybody has
a girlfriend my mom and my dad are like
well we're the only people we've ever
known you
can't have a girlfriend you got to have
what can we control studies you have to
have good grades and anything that gets
in the way of your progress academically
as far as we know because of our
experience will impede your ability to
live a fruitful life like all this
social stuff you want to do we don't
know what the [ __ ] that is
I mean that's you're just like a Martian
basically they know how to raise you to
be an engineer yeah right a PhD by so
did they get their PhDs in India and
then yeah they got their PhDs in India
and that's where they met in grad school
huh they got married they were separated
for two years not I mean because my dad
had my mom had to finish school and my
dad had to work and then they moved to
the US and then they I popped out and
it's like I'm your mom work at NIH or
something they both work at the National
Institutes of Health my dad was at Johns
Hopkins my mom is in the National
Institute of dental research and my dad
is in the National Cancer Institute so
he's working with antibiotic resistance
strains of cancer chemotherapy resistant
strains and trying to figure out how
cancerous cells become resistant right
and my mother what happens is this is
like taking a deep dive when cats get
ready a cat's when people get radiation
treatment their salivary glands die and
they're unable to produce saliva which
as we're talking now like everyone can
hear how wet my mouth is if it was dry
like and I had no ability to swallow
he'd be a problem you get mouth
infections so she's trying to look at
the calcium channel of the parotid gland
in the salivary gland to figure out how
to turn it on and off essentially where
is the protein the miniscule microscopic
protein that you can turn on and off so
to put that into the context of my life
take your kid to work day was like sit
down at a table get four pins get a rat
put the pins in the rats hands dissect
the rat with the rest of her staff with
the rest of graduate students and like
PhDs and just sit at a table at nine
years old and cut out the parotid gland
and then get a bucket of liquid nitrogen
yeah throw rubber gloves and you're like
microphone like what do you have any tap
dancing shoes yeah right and I'm just
joking and I'm like button happy happy
happy people people people
and I love people and it just took a
while for them to see where my skill set
was and you know part of that was
stubbornness like I fought and I clawed
like a war of attrition yeah I was just
like no I'm gonna be I'm I'm just you
know I'm doing theater this did you have
a clear picture like this is what my
life is gonna be like when you started
doing theater in high school where
you're like that's it that's this is
Mike immediately right Wow as soon as I
got on stage I was like I'm in water
like whatever it is for you like I am
this is oxygen like I am breathing right
now I've never been so comfortable in my
life and did you get was there a good
theater department at your high school
to support you like did you have a drama
teacher that could see like hey this guy
really wants this or this guy has some
talent that I can foster or were you
just trying to figure it out yourself no
I had Carol Solomon was an English
teacher and Harriet middle burger was my
drama teacher in high school and this
man I think his name was Herbert but I
definitely know his last name was
Weisgerber Henry her I don't know
Weisgerber and I had friends and I had
people and my peers to sort of work with
and compare myself to and then there was
this thing in DC called the young
Americans of Washington which was like
the juilliard of Maryland and I went and
did a show with them and was around
these people that were really really
talented a lot of many of those people
made it to Broadway and like are working
today and I was just like okay like you
know how it is like even with swimming
you're like okay I can I can hang like I
can swim with these with these guys like
I'm I'm okay here like Charles Barkley
talks about I'm a huge basketball fan
and Charles Barkley talks about like
when you're in high school you like play
and you play and you're like okay like
I'm a pretty good high school player
like I'm like at the top like I'm in the
top 5% and then you get to college and
you're like back at the bottom mmm and
you work and you sort of see how people
play and you're like okay like I'm
pretty good for the college level and
then you get to the pros
and it's a much the rules change the
rules and the pros are how do you look
how tall are you what ethnicity are you
what is our world view of what someone
like you is capable of doing how do you
communicate with the fans and the press
yeah and so the rules the pros are a
little bit different as far as acting is
concerned it's not merit-based it's not
as it's very subjective it's not as
objectively like I jump higher I score
more points it can be like oh yeah
you're much funnier than him but he's a
white guy and we need a white guy to be
the lead of this show we can't put an
Indian do it on a billboard are you
crazy
but the point you're making is
essentially that you felt comfortable
here you knew you could hang and as he
started to I kind of move up from high
school to college etc like you were at
home you never felt like you're out of
your day and that comes from my parents
mm-hmm and I will say this as not a
negative but that is an entitlement that
they gave me and it's a confidence and a
belief and and probably it's their love
and support that allows me to walk into
most rooms expecting to get a job it's
an insane I know it's an insane
irrational confidence skill or gift or
mental quirk or I don't know it doesn't
it doesn't exist in any other place yeah
like how did they instill that in you
and what does that look like and feel
like it just feels like I'm gonna be
okay it's a real feeling of like no
matter what happens you can do those
yeah mom and dad will be there like I
think it's from a very young age like if
I mess up mom and dad will be there now
it's my responsibility now as an adult
to not have that be a constant safety
net right or to let that you let that
turn you into being an [ __ ]
exactly which happens to a lot of people
now my mom and my dad and I have a
wonderful relationship and I think that
they can rely on me and expect me to be
a certain person every time they see me
as opposed to some erratic loco friggin
firecracker of a human being well I feel
like you had to earn the success that
you're experiencing now in a kind of an
interesting way that we're going to get
into and a member that probably gran
you and allows you to be a little more
connected with humility than somebody
who just hit the ground running well
cause the guys like you for sure it's
like I didn't know who you were
you're just like the soft-spoken dude
was pretty good hair it's great your
hair's just incrementally much modeled
my haircut after you dude I know there's
nothing she gets back long again I mean
you can but this is so suave my friend
you should be in a tweed jacket at all
times with this haircut I'll think I
know this is an audio podcast but your
boy rich role is looking good ladies and
gentlemen all right now back to Utah
right fine fine fine
so I'm happy to come on your podcast
when you decide that you're gonna get
back and do it again oh man okay so what
were you so it like here's the thing so
so you go to Tisch you go to NYU yes
yeah I mean that's pretty [ __ ] dope
like to get into Tisch yeah did you get
right directly into the acting program
did and the road to that was did you
apply to a whole bunch of drama oriented
colleges what happened was I was sitting
in the back of the minivan and told my
parents after a show I'd like to be an
actor this is what I'd like to pursue
for my life and my mother said as to
speak to what we started this podcast
with the only Indian on television is a
Pooh on The Simpsons and he's a [ __ ]
cartoon what makes you think you as a
human Indian can make get anything done
that's some truth talk from mom cars
yeah it's because it's like look she you
know engineer lawyer doctor
you know we're immigrants we want to
make sure that our child is educated and
upwardly mobile of course he wants to be
an actor there's absolutely no Indians
now on screen at the time no I mean it's
a pretty logical right conclusion and my
I don't know again I don't know what it
is but there was no doubt in my mind
that I'd be able to succeed and I don't
think that that's um I don't know what
that is and I don't champion it I think
that sounds like something that goes
beyond just the way your parents parents
did you like some deep conviction like
some past life [ __ ] it's like a supreme
stupidity it's like just that it's as
dense as you can possibly be
it's single mind but not
hope like unknowing yeah I've never had
a hope it's always been just there
mm-hmm
and that's what's gonna happen and what
was the idea like what was if you had to
visualize what that look like in terms
of where you saw your soul at that time
Will Smith mm-hmm like that was my hero
I was like yeah I'll do this Fresh
Prince thing like I'll go I'll be a
rapper I'll be a TV guy like I'll go do
it and now like you know there's a it's
a good life and I mean at that time my
parents my mother had no clue what
acting was like my parents were like all
right cool cool cool cool cool
you want to do this acting thing my
father now I know it was like if he's
passionate about something you let him
do it that's what it is at the time he
was like no you're like you couldn't say
he couldn't be like yeah I changed her
dream that's what I did my father came
from a small city waking up at 6 a.m.
and basically wrote his way out of a
tiny city into the preeminent spot in
his field right in the United States of
America yeah to be at NIH doing cancer
research I mean that's that's the top of
the heap if you look up my last name on
Google it's my dad my mom and then me
uh-huh that's amazing yeah we also might
be the only people with our lives in the
planet I don't know I don't know but I
mean did they or did they ever say
listen okay you want to be an actor well
maybe you should go back to India and do
the Bollywood thing no cuz they knew my
Hindi is horrible like I can't really
dance I can't hang up no answer at all
hell no I would I'd be tossed aside I'd
be cast aside like many Indian Americans
who tried to do the same thing like
they're like uh we're good all right so
you're at NYU that's like the perfect
place for you yeah I mean what happened
was is they made me apply just real
quick they made me apply to 15 schools
or 16 schools half academic and half
acting and I did all my auditions myself
I didn't have any help and my mother was
like I don't know what to do so she went
to this director Harriet Miller middle
burger who's actually the art teacher at
school and was like do you think my son
can be a professional actor and this
poor woman Harriet middle Berger who is
an art teacher at a high school in
Gaithersburg Maryland or Rockville
Maryland has to decide my favor and she
what she says will determine
heritage yeah he's got focus issues but
he's talented if he puts his mind to
anything he'll be good at it like the
diplomatic answer and that was enough
for my mom to be like okay and then
getting into a school at that time when
it might still be as prestigious as NYU
was a big deal in building their
confidence yeah I would imagine that
would allow them to like feel like sort
of exhale a little bit like NYU grade
school first whatever happens with this
acting you went to Stanford I did yeah
you did
yeah cool but then I went after I
finished Stanford I want to lived in New
York City and I dated a girl who was an
NYU student in the acting program there
and I had you know I met a bunch of
those PMSing no does not differ Messing
nobody you would know but uh I got it I
got like a sense of that program and
kind of what goes on there it's so
impressive yeah it was it was fun man I
don't know how you are in an academic
environment but as a creative person and
when you're trying to express something
that is so intrinsically a part of who
you are especially when what you do is
so tied into the rhythm of humor and
comedy and it's not about diving into
the mind of a character it's about
finding the music in the moment and
finding and mining the laughter and
that's an instinctual thing you can
learn it to some degree but the language
of laughter is so as you can see I'm
like contorting my body it's so in the
back of my neck and in the base of my
spine and in my stomach and it's in my
by my earlobes it's like I can it's an
energy and so when you go to school and
you have that's the language that I
spoke at the time and people are like
you should be playing princes and you
should be this and don't be a funny man
be a serious man dude do you want people
to take you seriously don't you this is
acting and I'm like no I want that
experience that I had when that woman
came in with the frowny face and then
left beaming I do it for that I don't
want to do it for critical peers I don't
want to do it for anyone who has an
understanding of how the magic works I'm
not doing magic for other magicians I'm
doing it for the people that
to be transported somewhere so that was
like a very hard thing for me to do now
the vocal training at NYU the physical
training the spine work the Alexander
Technique the the core work the breath
were invaluable for like doing a six
show week in the stage play and how much
of it do you think is trainable like you
there's this kind of ongoing
conversation about like oh well did you
study my snare or did you what was the
you know what school of thought did you
you know what did under which did you
train and I'm always curious like how
much of this is just like you just came
out of the womb like channeling this
like to use your phrase like magic like
there's a magic to it there's an energy
to it that you're just attuned to in a
certain way and yeah you can learn
certain techniques to hone your craft
and what you do and improve and and sort
of figure out different ways to approach
these characters but how much of that is
like nature versus nurture I think it's
I mean I love the school that it's
you're born with you're born with it and
some people are born with more and some
people are born with less we can call it
charm we can call it charisma we can
call it gravitas you know weight
depending on there's so many different
kinds of performance and they all
require a different set of skills and
how you like for me like I know that my
skill and my gift is in making people
feel good and laugh that's what I do I
entertain I'm a performer in that regard
I don't know that I'd consider myself an
actor but like if someone wants to call
me that cool I'll take the I'll take the
title but like mmm how I use my body
physically like probably very similar
like focusing which area of my spine do
I use for this character like there are
really fun ways to play with your body
that I didn't know before I showed up
like I was a jumping bean on stage I
couldn't sit still and then I had a
teacher be like hey man plant your feet
take the space you have so much energy
use it focus it that was helpful right
because I was embarrassed I was like
here I am thinking I'm hot [ __ ] and like
my teacher goes up on stage and
he's the way I look and I looked
ridiculous like I'm like flopping it's
like Yoda and Luke Skywalker like yeah
yeah you have the force the force is
strong with you but like if the force is
just you know losing out of your pores
and like you know yeah it's not focused
it's not channeled in a very intentional
way yeah and it's also that thing of
like self-centeredness and narcissism
can really deter you as an artist right
because once you get so like when I was
battling right another like major moment
is like I'm like swinging my dick left
and right
bah bah bah bah bah India dick on your
forehead and like Tommy kale comes up to
me and is like hey man I get that you
come from an ego environment I get that
everything you do is to boost your own
ego we are operating as freestyle Love
Supreme in a world in which you rapping
about yourself is infinitely less
important than you and interesting then
say you rapping about oatmeal if you can
rap about oatmeal or The Incredible Hulk
or the Los Angeles Clippers with as much
dexterity and passion as you rap about
yourself then I'll be interested mmm and
when you can do that when you can take
the focus off of you then you then you
might you might have something and
that's powerful life advice dude change
my whole game it opened me up to a world
of expression and improvisation that I
up until that point had not experienced
and it took so much pressure off of me
that I didn't know was there mm-hmm
because ultimately like I don't feel
that great about myself who can feel
that good about themselves all the time
I'm like a skinny Indian dude ostracized
unattractive like only child grew not
growing up in a country that my parents
didn't understand like super sensitive
never felt like I fit in and like I'm
the I'm up on stage being look I'm the
man I'm gonna beat you well fronting you
know I mean exactly fronting they would
have fun exactly and and and I don't you
know I don't really blame you for that
like I think it takes a certain kind of
courage and like just like balls to go
I'm
to be an actor I'm Indian there's no
there's nobody as pay has paved this
road in front of me yeah so how else are
you going to break down those doors and
get noticed without a little bluster
yeah there's a lot of just false
confidence moments for sure yeah I'm
just like I'm sure you got taken down a
peg too here and there always yeah I
mean always was there who was the first
like kind of breakout Indian performance
you know ahead of you where you were
like wow something's happening so I mean
you have guys like on pori the
old-school guys like ohm poori who did
city of joy and then you which was like
in the 90s with Patrick Swayze not a
great movie but um an Oscar Uddin Shah
and then you know there
aasif Mandvi was there for a long time
right but he was sort of under the radar
and he was he wasn't on my radar the
first guy that I saw and you know he
loves when I shout him out and it's true
is like a Jane I do in office space when
I saw him in this cult classic movie I
was like oh the oh geez going in like
that's my guy
oh gee and I do is my guy and he's still
my guy he knows he's my og and like I
don't know if he listens to this podcast
I mean everybody on planet Earth listen
spike as I hope he does but he's he does
hit us up because I'd like to know
that's the first time I saw somebody
with brown skin and I was like ding ding
ding meaning okay cool
it's possible and then of course what
year was that I want to say 97 98 and
then of course Cowpen broke through and
that were there was this boom in around
the late 90s early 2000s of Indian
American produced independent cinema
there was this movie called chutney
popcorn American Dacey's ABC DS which
means American born confused they cease
there was like this little Renaissance
of independent Indian film right
none of the movies sorry guys were that
great but that's not the point the point
is that they were being done you know
what I'm saying and then Cowpen blew up
with Harold & Kumar and by the time I
was out of college I think Aziz Ansari
was doing stand-up
he was already doing human giant and
there were people making moves das
traces the music group was around with
hymns and um
Apple Apple now what is Harry's brother
Hari Kondabolu is brothers in that but
he's is a buddy of mine and people were
making moves but a Jain idea was the
point where I like it's gonna happen
what year what year was the Danny Boyle
movie Slumdog dog yeah
2001 was it or later I don't know it
seems like it's a long time maybe 2005
yeah within the last that had some of
the kind of the old-school Indian actor
do like the the like the game show host
dude yeah time right know Kapoor is the
man if anyone wants to see a great
Bollywood movie go see mr. India and
it's awesome he can he turns invisible
right it's taupe so the light bulbs kind
of going on and you're like okay like
there's some there's some there's some
people out there so what happens here's
the interesting thing about Hollywood
though and stereotypical nature of it
and the idea of boxes and as you and I
have I've followed you and your career
and your journey and path and boxes
don't exist like you are all about just
finding efficient spiritual ways to
express yourself and I think that is
what we hope for and we strive for is
people now the profession that I've
chosen is not so amenable to that
experience well the difference is that I
can I can speak into this microphone
directly to the audience there's no
intermediary yeah Hollywood is all about
you know doors that you're trying to
break down and you know committees and
all kinds of you know people that have
to sign off on projects getting made and
how they're made so you're asking me to
be your co-host job anytime dude I
accept it's so nice to do this with
somebody who's a good talker okay so it
takes all the stress away like it's it's
awesome man but but the to speak this is
a very good example of how Hollywood
works Oh Dave Patel the main actor in
Slumdog Millionaire movie wins the Oscar
right it mean Best Picture so it is the
most lauded movie of its year
and you'd expect a star of an
oscar-winning picture to have so many
[ __ ] scripts at his doorstep that he
immediately launches into movie stardom
it should be that easy right any other
Best Picture winner you look at
guaranteed if you have a an actor of
indeed like a white actor or even now
thankfully black actors they will have a
career so fast well they'll they'll at
least get tons of options an opportunity
exact and if they make the wrong choices
right those they don't execute well
that's only gonna last so long the
opportunities will immediately be
available yeah the door will open so Deb
Patel Lee did this movie Slumdog
Millionaire cut to a year later two
years later I'm sitting in a room with
Dev Patel star of the oscar-winning
movie Slumdog Millionaire and both of us
are going head to head auditioning for
Aaron Sorkin for the newsroom what the
[ __ ] is Deb Patel doing in a room with
me mm-hmm
because at that point I have no credits
maybe I've done two failed pilots I've
gotten a very fancy Lucille Lortel
nomination for an off-broadway acting
award and I've won a few rap battles and
I'm in an improv freestyle group but how
many but in the script I would imagine
it called for Indian American actor yes
how many dudes are there there's only
like 10 dudes right yeah but he's why
not the offer
I'm also there's a TV show and he's
number eight or nine or ten on that call
she this is the star of an oscar-winning
[ __ ] movie hmm and maybe it's the
decisions he made but from my
perspective I'm like yo man you couldn't
have [ __ ] this up that quick like what
what is going on so that is the type of
thing like right Kunal and I did book it
but he shouldn't have had to audition
exactly
Kunal Nayyar who Big Bang Theory this is
another guy we're talking about nine
seasons what are they making 1.5 an
episode like crazy they're breaking bank
and he and I are sitting in a room
together for a role in a Ron Howard
movie the title I can't remember and we
both meet Ron Howard and we have to meet
and I'm like
I've just come from South by Southwest
I've been rocking it with my group I am
hungover as [ __ ] and I'm just like uh uh
uh uh and here's Kunal Nayyar a
certified television behemoth star what
am i doing in the room with him why is
he not just getting the offer that's why
that's where it when it's like we need
an Indian dude let's have options it's
like no man reach out to the worldly
bank on that dude
yes bro he's he's on the number one show
on television why am i coming up it why
am i call I think there's a weird thing
that happens which is if it was a white
dude you'd be like oh well that movie's
succeeded because that white dude
carried the movie and have so current so
much charisma and when there is you know
an ethnic actor for lack of a better you
know John White a Kia then the the
thinking is well oh it was the director
or it was there's a dismissiveness right
yeah it's just built into the whole
thing you know I'll speak to that really
quickly which I did barbershop right
right and that was interesting again I'm
the only one like me in that movie like
I'm surrounded by amazing black actors
and comedians and they're incredible but
I'm still the only Indian in the entire
room and that's an interesting
experience too like I'm always sort of
the odd man out but and that's fine
because I'm here to work with artists
ultimately more than I am what ethnic
background they are right I'm here to
work with talented and great people who
inspire me but I asked one of the
executives of that movie I was like do
you think Aziz or an Indian person could
headline a studio film right now he's
like absolutely not that'll never happen
you can do an independent movie good
luck but to speak to what you said about
a white actor carrying a movie so if I'm
sitting in a room with all Indian people
or Indians for the Pinot's you know
Asian non white people and you go hey
man who in the group is most like Tom
Cruise well no because we've been
watching movies with straight white male
leads for so long that we know which one
of us is Tom Cruise we know who the Will
Smith is like and straight you know
Smith is an outlier right he's like this
but a movie star transcended race
yeah and Denzel right and so like why
does he have to transcend race that's
the crazy thing but anyway like we'll
know we'll be like yo coo coo coo coo
coo but if you sit with your friends
with are in a white group a group of
white males and you're like which one of
you guys is most like Jackie Chan can
you answer that yeah no that's tougher
greater because you haven't had the
experience of empathizing and being in
the shoes of asian-americans
for your entire life I've been doing
this my whole life
comparing myself to a white ideal or in
some cases a black ideal because those
are the predominantly the two choices
you have when growing up in this country
and you pick a side you either wear a
polo shirt or you were you know Tim's
and like that's kind of like though
those are your choices so that's just
that's something that Dante Basco who is
an actor and a friend of mine also he
played Rufio in the movie hook mm-hmm he
brought that up to me we worked on a
song together recently and I was like
that's so that's on point if you sit
down with a group of white people in his
life which one are you guys most like
good Karsh like no no why would anyone
want to be like good gosh I don't want
to be an Indian dude it isn't
interesting like reversal of perspective
though yeah I want to think about that a
little bit more but I think you know
look it is changing it is improving
perhaps not as quickly as it as it
should but I think it's an interesting
time you know look Camille had it you
know the big sick was super lauded I
think more people should have seen that
movie great movie and if you haven't you
should and you're getting you seem to be
getting quite a few opportunities like
the doors are opening for you so uh you
know you're having success you're on the
cusp of bigger success how do you think
about how you carry that mantle of being
of being a you know an indian-american
actor like do you feel like a certain
responsibility and how you communicate
around that and do you think of it in
terms of you know how you advocate
for change or like what is your
disposition around the whole thing I
feel a deep sense of responsibility I am
Indian American and I am an actor to
deny that would be foolish I've
experienced several ups and downs as a
result of you know my ethnic background
and how people perceive that and I feel
blessed at the same time this is not a
black-and-white issue I am very grateful
to work I'm not saying that like this is
what a lot of people like you work all
the time what do you have to complain
about it's not about being complaints
about being a spokesman or a
representative of a community that's
underrepresented that's what I'm here
for
for instance is Good Morning America
thing like hurry is in Chicago they
wanted to talk to hurry hurry said no so
they asked me now I could be like I
don't want to go on Good Morning America
like I got I don't want to eat a
cheesesteak and go to bed but somebody
has to show up somebody has to represent
the community do you think about that
like 14-year old good cars at home honey
I wasn't have any role models who might
be tuning in to watch that yeah you're
speaking to the exact reason yeah
because as a kid like Will Smith was my
role model Michael Jordan was my role
model Michael Jackson was my role model
bo Jackson was my role model like maybe
who else was there
jean-claude Van Damme you know I mean
none of those guys look like me right
mm-hmm but the amount of people now who
are like hey man I saw you in pitch
perfect or when I saw you on Mindy
project young people you know your
podcast really means something to us
please keep doing it like it's so good
to know that somebody like us is out
there going through the same stuff that
we go through as creative people every
day that means a lot and I'm sure you
get the same type of response in your
field and as you know like that's I mean
it's really really helpful it's super
helpful as I go through my own life
knowing that I'm not alone and that the
work that I do is not being seen as
either good or bad just being seen as a
representation of possibility does that
make sense yeah makes sense
you know I think it would be great to
kind of contextualize it a little bit
because if you look at your IMDB and
you're like oh dude works all the time
like look at all those credits cuz it
goes from one thing to the next and I
know you well enough to know that that's
not necessarily you know it hasn't been
this like linear upward upwardly-mobile
trajectory yeah are you so like what do
people you know who have some
familiarity with you or you or your work
like what do they not get about like
what you had to do to get to the place
that you're at what do they not get you
mean like how sort of like oh yeah
you're Indian but doesn't seem to have
been a barrier for you look at you you
work all the time oh but you just don't
see the nose my friend like you don't
hear the nose isness of nose yeah you
don't you this is part of that nuclear
pellet thing right Richard Dreyfuss came
and spoke to my college class and he
looked sad I don't know what that book
man was going through someone asked a
question he was like I had a nuclear
pellet in me once and it died and I've
never been able to get it back and he
said that [ __ ] and I was like this sad
[ __ ] higher was that this is
2003 for I went to his house for a
project and it must have been two
thousand four two thousand maybe two
thousand six he wasn't around that same
time and I had a similar experience with
him where I had left kind of feeling
bummed out a little bit bummed and just
totally I was like you're gonna sit in a
room full of open sponge minds and say
some [ __ ] horrible [ __ ] like that
keep your gut it's like be of service
teach anyway mine I think he is a
teacher now I hope so he's like a
professor or something
I tell me what go ahead my nuclear
pellet isn't gonna die because I get to
be here and share with you someone who
inspires me and fills me up I get to go
and hopefully be willing to be educated
but the know right the know is constant
I've done 13 pilots 12 of them have
failed and every one of those pilots had
a price tag attached to it right
this is what its gonna be I've worked
with some of the best people on projects
you will never see every year pilot fail
pilot right for people that are
listening that that aren't quite
familiar when you do a pilot you and as
a lawyer I used to negotiate these deals
I mean you're basically signing a
contract for the next seven years of
your life yeah and as an actor like
literally your life would change in such
an unbelievably dramatic way literally
overnight if the pilot gets picked up
and goes to series you go friends and
networks yeah you go from having a lot
of free time and making let's say let's
say our good year you make $50,000 to
making 1.2 million dollars a year for
seven years right immediately and still
living in a one-bedroom apartment for
$1,200 a month now I don't know what
it's like because that's never happened
I did finally break through that ceiling
this year with show times like my famous
we did one season and got canceled I
know that that's a win for me dude I
just did my first full season of
television after ten years thirteen
pilots of being like is this one gonna
go is this one is this one gonna go all
those pilots what was the one that you
thought like this one is incredible it's
gonna go or the people involved it's
just too good to not Oh to not go two
years ago Kevin Connolly Vanessa
Williams myself
jamie-lynn Sigler Tim McAuliffe writer
fantasy life it was called based on the
fantasy football guys book whose name I
can't remember right now but everybody's
yelling at your their car stereos right
now calm down people it was a show about
Fox Sports Network shot about football
and on Fox it was like it was like Fox
it was like here we go here you go
single camera just spoon-feed success
into you and we got football players Rob
Gronkowski was there Russell Wilson was
a guy like we could have just gotten
anyone all the time and for some reason
didn't get picked off didn't get picked
up it's so crazy that model though they
spent so much money and then they don't
pick these things up nobody
ever sees these pilots they go to some
graveyard somewhere and because the
network owns the story it never goes any
further like I feel like with all of
these outlets now there should be more
fluidity with all of these pilots that
don't get picked up where there's some
flexibility that they can be sold to
other places and get developed and come
out and shows I mean that's kind of what
happened to me that's sort of the
process I'm in right excuse me in right
now which is which is where I'm at I
mean to really speak to like why my
career has like gotten better like you
know I know you have a history with
booze mm-hmm
like I was I was not living a good
lifestyle and I'll tell you like the
most poignant story is this if it's a
little bit long this is what I'm here to
talk about dude so to speak to freestyle
Love Supreme
what happened is about seven years ago
six years ago Lin does this Alexander
Hamilton song at the White House well
let's back it up even further a little
bit sure if we could where do you first
meet Lin oh in that room and that was
you didn't know him before then no we're
like two dogs sniffing each other butts
and being like I think we might be from
the same litter and where does the
partying come in like when you're in New
York and at NYU and yeah I would say
that I was full blown by 18 or 19
uh-huh I would say I was like going hard
in the paint oh you weren't you were
ramping up in high school then you get
to New York City which is just like
Disneyland for alcoholics yeah high
school I was a pretty good kid mm-hmm
and then once I got to New York by
sophomore junior year of college I would
had completely checked out like I was
like you know whatever it is to all the
shrooms all the acid everything right
like I'd tried I don't need to get into
specifics but you know we did a lot of
crazy like fish related behaviors you
know what I'm saying or like fish like
phi-1 fish the band like string cheese
incident yeah my gosh oh I'm freezing I
don't even know what that is I
String Cheese Incident and I fish sound
tried sector 9 I'm trying to remember
all of my friend chases favorite bands
because I just went wherever he went
because that's where the stuff was so
yeah by the time I'm 2021 this is my
lifestyle and I feel guilty about it I'm
like I probably shouldn't be doing this
like this isn't what a good Indian kid
should do like you know I'm not able to
show up to things with as much gusto but
it's Who I am like this is hip-hop this
is New York this is like 22 men's what
we do smoke weed everyday' like this is
the lifestyle you know and like when you
don't when you're not getting work you
can always sell and you can make at
least enough money to like stay stay
afloat
you're not losing money that's for sure
you want to jail a couple times for like
some little things but like no biggie do
no biggie
yeah so what I was spray-painting in the
lower Eastside it's like it's what you
got to do the dumbest there's some cred
yeah I was in this hip-hop group called
the beat arts bad name I love those guys
and we spray-painted on the wall in big
gold letters the beat arts will outrun
you and then in two seconds it was like
and we did not run we did not skip jog
or walk
we stayed stationary and went directly
to jail ha ha ha uh-huh and it was like
little things like that like one time I
had a open container on the subway and
that's nothing that's a ticket
that's no I thought you could still can
you not do it in the brown bag nope no I
say we got we got pinch thing I had a
prior from that spray-painting incident
so you go directly to jail now what and
where I got lucky and I have never told
this story but that's crazy because the
one thing about New York City cops is
they got their eyes on like the most
important [ __ ] like they can't be
bothered with some dude in the subway
with an open container me and my buddies
are what you like that's amazing but
they would even care yeah I don't know
what we did but I will tell you this
like for the white people listening you
guys really have an ability to yell at
cops
that the rest of us don't and you should
appreciate that and use it as much as
possible if I was a white person I'd be
yelling at a police officer at least
once a day I would just be I still don't
think it's a good idea if you're white
but certainly not as dire as it would be
if not to do that at least three times a
day you should say something mean to a
cop and just be like haha that's my
privilege in life I'm only half joking
but uh so that was a one of those
experiences where look we get pinched
we're only there for an overnight but
here's the thing
I've got weed on me which is a
misdemeanor but I've also got a bag of
cocaine in my pocket and it was like in
that little coin pocket that you have in
your jeans and I was like my friend
charlie is yelling at the cops and he's
being you know obnoxious and I was like
you have to shut the [ __ ] up like I'm
actually in a problem situation here and
lucky for me by the grace of whatever
obviously it's my luck because at this
point on the center of the universe and
I've done enough shrooms to know that
I'm Jesus
but like the cop searched my jeans with
rubber gloves and when he went into that
pocket he didn't feel the bag so I'm
sitting in jail with cocaine in my
pocket and nobody knows Wow and they let
us our key six hours later and I'm just
like so if you if you had been busted
for that felony oh yeah I mean I'm not
going home that night yeah that's for
sure there's no way right and so it got
spared there all right so let's
fast-forward to to Lindh
yeah so basically like so I meet Lane
blah blah blah we do that we're there
and then seven years ago Linds like I
got something for you I got something
good I'm working on something special I
got something for you and was Linn a
student at NYU no Lin went to Wesleyan
we met we met when I was a senior coming
out of senior year in college so I met
all those guys I met Lynn Critias
freestyle lobster exactly and we did
that we went to Vancouver for Just for
Laughs festival we we performed we
performed a lot we've been onstage
together hundreds of times and then
Lynn's like I got this day
I got this thing you know this Hamilton
thing you want to do it and I was just
coming off a pitch perfect and I was hot
[ __ ] in it and I also at this point was
like living a lifestyle which was a
daily I was in a daily lifestyle at this
point daily using yeah daily drinking
and we did Hamilton what became Hamilton
excuse me at Lincoln Center we started
that and I was like oh so it was like
you're developing the material with him
and like yeah we didn't like who else is
like the first time it was me and Chris
john rua james monroe michael hart so
basically just freestyle Love Supreme
dudes kind of yeah Ben's like I got this
thing did you have a sense like whoa
this is like this is a thing so at first
when we did it at Lincoln Center when we
did like a Hamilton mixtape I think is
what it was called and I for an audience
or yeah awful audience uh-huh and I
played Aaron Burr which is the lead role
that won a Tony for Best Actor you know
it was good it was like yeah Lin's dope
this is my friend he's dope I'm dope
like we're all good this is gonna be
good
like I have no context I'm like I just
did pitch perfect my movie like I'm
blowing up like I'm good I'm on the
Mindy project about the wait maybe I
hadn't done Mindy project yet I was full
of German vigor and full of that [ __ ]
and I was more concerned about where the
party was that after than the work
itself which is what I learned later on
when I stopped drinking is that what
happened after was so much more
important than the experience itself I
wanted to know where we were going what
we were doing who we were doing it with
and whatever happened on stage is like
the least of my [ __ ] interests and
priorities so fast forward a few months
and a total lack of appreciation for
this unbelievable opportunity oh it fell
into your lap all day every day
appreciation you should be so lucky to
have me like so few months pass and then
we go up to Poughkeepsie to a New York
stage and film to workshop again and
then now we've got sort of what became a
lot at the core group you got Chris
Jackson Dobby joined I was there
Joshua Henry who just played Aaron Burr
here in LA if you guys got a chance to
see him he was he's incredible and
several other folks so I can't remember
right now but you've got Tommy Cal you
got Alec slacker more the music director
you've got Lynn and here's the thing I'm
not a trained musical theatre guy it's
not like I can just show up and be dope
I have to work and like I have a few
skills which help which is to say that
like if I hear something I can mimic it
I've got sort of like an audio graphic
thing at least that's what Alex says but
if you're drunk at 9:00 in the morning
or 10:00 in the morning that's gr you go
to work no man yeah so I went through
that week with great with an inability
to perform in the way that they wanted
me to and knew that I could my did
people like dahveed like show up
understanding like oh this is this is
gonna be like a big thing like I'm here
a hundred and ten percent
yeah for sure people took it seriously
and Chris Jackson sat me down and he was
like you know this is their life this is
Lin and Tommy and Alex this is their
future this is how they're gonna put
their kids through college this means
the world to them and you know it's not
some little [ __ ]
it's Tommy kale and lin-manuel Miranda
like we already done been through in the
heights you saw what that was you're
[ __ ] up and I was like Lynn's songs
are too hard and I kids sing them he's
like you know every Yelp and whoop to
every Michael Jackson song ever written
don't you why can't you learn Lynn's
stuff it's happened to telling you this
Christopher Jackson who played George
Washington right who's my big brother in
freestyle she's trying to have your back
and go look man you can do this you have
the skills but you gotta sort your [ __ ]
out yeah you got to focus
mm-hmm and meanwhile I'm at the bar
every night unable to do that so we
perform I am underwhelming in my
performance right and to fast-forward
quite a bit obviously I'm not sitting
here talking to you about my starring
role and Hamilton they had to go in a
different direction they were it wasn't
for me at that time I was unable to meet
them
because of what was going on in my life
which is really embarrassing and hard to
say to a bunch of people in their cars
who just yelled at me for not knowing a
fantasy football guy but yeah well
everyone likes to think that that they
would have quit themselves differently
but I think it's it's so powerful man so
and and and I it takes courage to tell
that story and I appreciate you sharing
it with everybody so what happens then
is like you oh sorry but yeah but I'm
just saying like you know that it's it's
such a palpable thing like to to not to
be so in your immaturity in your disease
to not really understand the opportunity
in front of you and to be unable to
avail yourself of your god-given talent
to just show up and do what everyone
else is doing and then in retrospect you
know fast forward several years later to
look back through the rearview mirror
and to see and truly appreciate what
Hamilton became it must have been very
difficult for you to not do the you know
coulda shoulda
what uh what would life have been like
hell I just decide to showed up sober of
course I did that would have what
happens is I get sober and as I'm
getting sober and Brent and for anyone
who's dealt with substance stuff or
who's struggling with it you know that
when you and you know when you first
turn turn off the booze and the drugs
and stuff you're a babe you're a
brand-new person
everything is raw what am i my routine
was based on this behavior I now have to
change all my behaviors Who am I so I'm
this brand new person in the world and
I'm like look at me I'm brand new and
I'm special and I'm clean and I'm doing
everything I gotta do to be a good guy
and a cool guy and a nice guy and
everywhere I look everywhere I go in
this new experience the specter and
shadow of my biggest mistake is over me
and blocking out everything else because
people know you do a quick Google search
it's like oh you played Aaron Burr and
everyone knows I'm friends with Lin
we're homies we're very good friends so
it's not like and they
supported me right like they fully
everyone is like nobody was like hey man
you should probably keep drinking like
everyone was supportive so it's one of
those things where now I'm sober
Hamilton has blown the buck up but did
Lin fire you or like how did that go
down they just kind of said this is kind
of not gonna work direction worker and I
called Tommy and I was like hey man like
what's up like we're going to the public
and he was like no dude like I'm really
glad I know now why you dropped the ball
the way you did but what you did we had
to move on it doesn't work for us
and I was like Kent can i audition again
he said yeah but I mean I knew I wasn't
gonna get a pass so but I flew myself
out to New York I prepped the material
showed up early and I sang and I did my
best and it was [ __ ] humbling a [ __ ]
man it was one of those like and they
walked out of the room and I was
changing and I know where to go I was
like in New York for a day mm-hmm
was newly sober I was just trying to
keep my [ __ ] together and I know that if
that went a long way for them of like
whoa this egotistical piece right that's
an act of humility you know it'll be
like hey I'm gonna say I [ __ ] up I'm
gonna come up and it had in hand and
like and I didn't even realize that's
what I was doing honestly like it had to
be explained to me by Tommy he had to be
like when you did it this this is how I
felt so Hamilton blows up and it hurts
right I'm like there I get to see the
show and like they're giving me this
unprecedented it's like nothing nothing
in culturally it was it was just a the
biggest outlier ever oh yeah blew up in
the way that it did and it's all my best
friends in it so like they're sending me
birthday messages in costume like Lynne
like Lynne and I basically the way we
communicate is through freestyle rap
videos so text them back we text back
and forth video so I don't know how many
we have at this point like if and
someone anyone ever archived it it's
like five she put that together that
would be amazing
yeah we should we should but I don't
yeah it's like our thing right but like
anyway like we look for instance this
week was a chicken box and a shingle
rap videos we're done I don't know if
anyone would find them interesting suit
I would I think you are under estimating
how much people would be into that will
uh I'll talk to him about it and I know
he'll be like really dude
let's not but I say some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
um well there is something kind of nice
and beautiful and pure about just having
like a private yeah like friendship like
that that's not for public consumption
it just keeps us in touch in a fun way
um go ahead I interrupted you that's
okay so it blows up and it hurts it
hurts a lot to not be there and like to
see your really good friends doing
something that you were a part of and
it's great success and at the time like
I'm not really like doing that much you
know I'm doing some pilots here and
there and like no TV show is ever gonna
be Hamilton you know what I mean and
you're just seeing people blow up like
Davi deserves it he's a homie we just
did a movie called blind spotting right
he got Sundance
I want to talk about that in a minute um
let me I saw blades through this story
it hurts it hurts it hurts and what
happens is is it culminates I've never
watched the Tonys but because I wanted
to beat the [ __ ] out of myself i watch
the Tonys it's the torturers yeah of
course I watch the Tonys and I see
Leslie Odom who's so talented by the way
like when I watch him play Aaron Burr I
realize and understand why I'm not
playing Aaron Burr like let's not get it
twisted that dude is for real ferocious
and if I had stayed with the project the
character would have been vastly
different but that's not what happened
they went into different direction and
Leslie I could never play Aaron Burr
today I don't have the chops but I watch
him get to Tony for Best Actor and I cry
cry woe is me tears how long have you
been sober at that point two years two
years maybe little less boo boo boo who
me and I'm so sad and as you know from
the work that we do to keep our minds
right I put pen to paper and I started
writing and I kept writing what is what
is the story
where are the feelings I wrote four or
five songs I wrote what ended up being
an 18
19 page treatment basically a graphic
novel and if I wrote a hip-hop musical
about a guy who missed out on being in
the biggest hip-hop musical of all time
about sobriety about missed
opportunities about how we deal with
being a new person in the world when the
one thing that you wish you had is
ubiquitous he's everywhere it's like if
you broke up with a girl and you missed
her and on every street corner was her
face right and I took that story
- Tommy Kael who directed Hamilton and I
was like Amen you know how much it hurts
you know what it is here's what I did
what do you think and he said well I
fired you from the first child let's do
this he's like I think this is
self-deprecating it's honest it's true
it's funny sweet in many ways it's like
a love letter to Lynne because otherwise
he wouldn't let me do it well I got
Lynne's blessing and you know we
developed it just to speak to what you
were saying earlier we developed it at
Amazon Amazon underwent this huge change
and now they're not going with like
quirky great shows they want to do like
Lord of the Rings style whatever they're
called you know they're spent a billion
dollars on that yeah so Amazon was like
yeah we're not really gonna do this now
so they bought it they bought it and
they gave it back oh they did give it
back because I remember when you sold it
yes so now we have we have it again and
we're going out with it but that the
point is is it's like that's the
best-case scenario you dropped a
freaking ball you tell a story about
dropping the ball and then the person
who [ __ ] dropped like who was like
you drop them it's more than that harsh
because what it is is it's taking
ownership of the character defects that
led to that situation it's writing about
it in an open and honest and vulnerable
way to take even deeper ownership of it
and then finding a way to convey that
story in a way that can be instructive
for other people to understand you know
what you went through and what you've
learned
from that I think it's like a beautiful
act of service done through the lens of
your art form
thanks I mean I hope so I mean but to
take like that thing that that I I mean
I just can't imagine like this the scope
of the pain like to like literally every
day have to see Hamilton everywhere you
turn yeah I can't imagine that and the
thing is dude you stayed sober through
that like if there was ever an excuse to
drink and say [ __ ] it but it's the
opposite the Hamilton is the excuse to
stay sober Hamilton is the reason like
when you look at it and you go [ __ ] it
we all have [ __ ] laugh [ __ ] it man I
want some champagne
god damn wines good come on Blue Label
gimme but then you go um you remember
Hamilton like do you remember what you
missed like do you remember do you know
like forget the friendships lost I mean
those are the most important things to
be honest like my mother my mother and I
and my father and I have a great
relationship
my mom doesn't cry she knows where I am
she knows that if I don't talk to her
for a couple of days I'm cool you know
what I mean like my friends asked me to
take care of their dogs they asked me to
officiate their weddings they asked me
to be best man at their weddings like
they know that when they make a plan
with me I'll show up like I'm here I'm
there but in terms of my career which
like you said is doing really well
I'm happy I'm blessed and I'm grateful
to be working with awesome people and to
show up on set and to be a version of
myself that is my ideal or at least
close to it in terms of how I treat
other people and you know that Hamilton
quote unquote loss it's a loss why am I
saying quote unquote is a great reason
to be like a man like you don't want to
go back on that bar right but it
presents a choice like that choice is
gonna break some people and it's gonna
make others right like you can look at
that and go hey man this is the the
biggest instructive lesson I'm ever
gonna learn yeah or you can just like
sort of use it to fuel victimhood and
tell yourself that European
[ __ ] until it's so painful that you're
faced with nothing no other choice but
to drink and use word but that's the
wonderful thing about getting sober and
hanging out with guys like you and being
on a spiritual path and being on a
growth is like you learn through
repetitive behaviors that are good to
have some self-love and integrity and
some self-esteem which I never truly had
I never built it up so I had like a
reserve so the Hamilton experience maybe
lowered my reserves it's certainly but
they but I was constantly feeling
refilling by spending time with people
like you like we all have missed
opportunities in our life and mine is a
great story it's certainly one of those
holy [ __ ] bro you [ __ ] up damn bro
that must you must feel like [ __ ] like
everyone I tell it to is like jaw drop
what's so direct but I mean you you
everybody I think you're right everybody
does have these maybe it's two steps
removed from that huge opportunity
because like oh I overslept because I
was hungover and I couldn't show up for
that meeting that would have led to me
meeting this other guy who would have
talked to that guy who would have talked
to that guy that then would have been
this thing like you just don't know yeah
I mean - that's right there in your face
it's like one plus one equals Hamilton
but like but the thing is is like at
throughout the experience I had the
support of people who understood the
feelings who weren't just like soldier
up boy like toughen up like you should
be happy this they were like wow that's
Prudhoe man like let's talk about it
what's going on what's what are those
feelings about you know what you can do
you can put pen to paper I don't I don't
have the muscle of self-pity it's so if
that self-pity muscle is atrophied so
much in sobriety and that's one of the
greatest gifts that I've been given is
that when the voice goes man
I'm a Butthead and nobody likes me
there's like a stronger voice that's
more alive and more grown-up and we're
taking care of that I never had before
that just goes hey man like I know
you're not feeling you're good you're
but like I got you you're taking care of
you're not like let's look at the resume
you're cool did you show up today for
all the things you need to show up for
is your bed made is the sink clean did
you brush your teeth cool
you seem like a good guy to me right
like what what was the bottom what
brought you in the bottom was I fell on
my face vanity the bottom was vanity I
fell on my face I woke up the next day I
looked in the mirror I had a black eye I
was bloody and I was like no no I was
like all I have to do is keep my dog
alive and not [ __ ] up my face and I have
I'm batting 50% which is a failing grade
and I got a call from a friend who had
been checking in on me and that was it
that's the last day I drank yeah I was
done how long has it been now 3 plus
yeah that's good yeah you're you just
celebrated a anniversary recently right
well yeah I think it's weird cuz it's
messed up I mean I I had that one day
outing about six years ago so I'm past
six years yeah but I went to rehab in 98
so it would be without that be you know
whatever 20 years 19 years but I reset
the clock after the you gotta like rest
bit or whatever did they have a good
bunny chess collection at your rehab I
don't remember
did you go to rehab I spent I'd spent
some time in summer camp you did okay
yeah no no I don't remember VHS there
was there would be a movie night
occasionally and there was a television
in like a communal room but it was more
like you know just going from group
session this to groups it's exhausting
yeah it's exhausting but part of its
awesome like there's part of me now
who'd be like that would be cool to like
go to rehab now for like 30 days it's
just like work on my [ __ ] just take a
week off here take a month off here you
could I remember when I was in rehab
somebody came for a stint who had had
like you know a fair amount of sobriety
here I can wait no no it's okay I just I
just move it because I move it because
um there was somebody who have like I
can't remember I mean it seemed like a
million years to me yeah
yes but but I was like you're choosing
to come here when you don't have like
you're not sure I couldn't understand it
but now I'm gonna either up there's one
other guy from that time named Jackson
and it's like you see that person in a
room across the room and it's like damn
we both I can't believe we're still here
mm-hmm
I can't believe we made it it's
incredible it said you know it's a
crippling disease
yeah it's a mint it's like it's insane
how did that kind of go over with the
with the parents when you had to talk
about to tell them what was going on oh
man it's brutal it's awful
my poor mother she's so so sad yeah she
was so scared and my dad really really
like soldier like I mean he really like
he read every book on addiction he read
every book on like the pleasure centers
in the brain and like what it is and
like he's got to put his science mind to
work on understanding because it is
scientific there's a dopamine receptor
there's there's a that's broken
so like when a normal person drinks five
drinks and that they're out of ten we
drink five drinks and we're out of eight
and we think we got a drink we have the
same tolerance but when I drink five I'm
at an eight and I will never get higher
than Nate so I will drink and drink and
drink and drink and drink and wonder why
I can't get drunk right whereas my
homies are like all right five drinks
I'm good I need a burrito I'm going home
the next day they wake up and they don't
feel the need the first thought in their
mind is not like oh when can I have more
of that you know that's how my body and
brain I've come to learn works if you
put a substance into my body
it could even be for tonight bro have
you heard of this video game for tonight
I have heard of it I'm awful but I've
been playing it for like a week
yeah and I'm terrible at it and it's one
it's the same thing these games last
depending on how bad you are between
five and twenty minutes every time a
game ends it's like 12 it's 12 a.m. look
- disco my dog one more game 12:30 one
more game one
yeah 130 that's that's the disease right
there in your face yeah 3:00 a.m. 3:00
3:30 well I don't have to go to the gym
tomorrow and I only have to see Richard
- so like that's what it is man
if you put something in me that's gonna
give me a boost I'm gonna abuse it right
so what are some of your routines to
keep it at bay the Beast I talk to you
guys like you who understand it exercise
I play a basketball three to four times
a week I'm at the gym several times a
week I make my bed making the bed in the
morning is a big one and like meditate
and I pray and we have a clubhouses
secret society yeah we have secret
societies that meet every now and then
and get tacos that's cool man and that's
kind of like how it is and there's
always somebody who is willing and
desperate for help and doesn't know how
to approach sobriety so so if somebody
like that is listening to this right now
and I assure you they're there are like
what do you say to that person I mean I
just said like what I usually am I'm the
funny one so if I'm like what's going on
how you doing yeah oh that sounds it
sounds pretty that sounds I mean it just
depends if so if somebody's feeling
stuck like they're in that and I know do
cuz I get I get crazy emails all the
time from people they're in that cycle
of addiction they just can't stop
drinking they can't stop using well you
don't know what to do if you like if
that dude called you up or that woman
called you up right now and said I'm
drunk right now I'm listening to the
podcast like tell me what to do well
there's a place at the front of the
phone book that you can look for and
they meet all the time and I would
suggest that you go meet some people we
all know how you feel we've all been
there I
it's hard to it was very felt good when
I found out I wasn't unique and that
when I wasn't special sometimes that's
very funny look like a guy who fed on
that for a long time being terminally
unique yeah but the best thing that's
happened to me is to just be like wow
cool I've got a family I got like a real
group of people and I'm so I'm so
special but I'm not unique does that
make sense like I am there's things
about me that make me who I am and part
of the thing that makes me special is
that I get to share something and be in
a support system with a bunch of people
so like if you're feeling it's so hard
because everyone you can't top some
people want tough love some people want
sweet love all I'll say is there's a
place you can go where you can get the
help that you need and it only costs $1
or it's free yeah it's definitely you
very lost a dollar I mean what I and I
agree with that and I would supplement
that by just saying if you don't want to
drink or use again you don't have to
that there is a solution available to
you it's not necessarily for everybody
who needs it it's for those who want it
so the question is do you want it and
are you willing to do what it takes to
to get it and if you are willing and you
are desperate and you feel broken and
alone that's a great place to start what
I would encourage you know anybody who's
listening to set aside whatever
preconceived ideas or notions you have
about the secret society find one in
your area show up raise your hand find
somebody you can talk to listen look for
the similarities rather than the
differences and and try to find somebody
who you identify with enough that you
can speak to them honestly and tell them
what's really going on in your life and
if you can get to that place of honesty
and connection with another human being
I think that's a pretty good start to
addressing what is only gonna get worse
unless you deal with it yeah you can try
something new and if you don't like it
you can go back to you shitty life
always go back you can always or
whatever is not working till where you
are right now and continue to be
miserable no problem but there is
there is a there's a way out and I think
you said it best like you just don't
ever have to feel this way ever again I
took that to heart and it changed my
life
mm-hmm and now you're employing spotting
yeah now we're at Sunday now I'm like
doing the Sun Dance with the homies
doing so wait you're in like game over
man you got like you get going away for
you can't can you touch can you talk
about what you're about to go do no you
can't but I'm going away for six months
to do it's big one of those big movies
yeah which I'm excited about soon as
that freaking contract gets written down
though I'm gonna tell the whole got to
come when is that because I could wait
on putting this up oh man and blind spot
so for people that don't know blind
spotting premiered at Sundance does it
you guys have a release date is that
good yeah usually I mean that was it
made a big splash oh yeah that blind
spot yeah stars daveed Diggs and Raphael
Castle written by Raphael as well
directed by our good buddy Carlos and
Janina gavankar who's my super homie
Jazmin safest Jones and myself and tons
of other great actors July 27th
Lionsgate releases that well game over
man with the workaholics boys is on
Netflix right now that is a wild action
comedy super gross like definitely fun
it's workaholics oh man it is so
inappropriate and I do awful things in
it and it's really fun and then there's
a movie I did with brie Larson which was
just released called basmati blues it's
a movie musical it's a romantic comedy
that's available on Amazon and on demand
and all those things and if you're in
India listening to the rich roll podcast
which I'm gonna guess is like at least
1.2 billion people
like in India listen to this podcast of
course please thought about it you can
go see it in theaters right now it's
playing in this plane throughout India
oh that's really cool and yeah you have
like an album coming out too right
I've got an album that I'm working on
called vanity it's got features from
Debbie Diggs Raphael Castle he's from
the sweatshop boys
one shanty Callie I think Lin is gonna
be on it Dante Basco I got a lot of
South Asian artists emcees and it feels
good it's just like
are you or do you have a label with that
are you doing that just all independent
independent that's pretty cool yeah
labels here's the thing ten years ago we
wrote songs me and my buddies those
songs are still on in TV and on TV and
in movies and nobody gets that money but
me and my two buddies hmm and we don't
have to we wrote a song on a plane ten
years ago called dang diggy to get it
dang a dang dang to get dang diggy diggy
too dang and those Dangs and those
Diggy's are still making this Bank at
the pig boy so they get licensed outs of
stuff yeah so that's why the independent
route uh-huh I've always I've always
done it that way I don't I don't like
sharing but you're always like you're
very industrious like you could just be
sitting and waiting for the phone to
ring and you're in this weird business
where you have very little control your
destiny you're just waiting for these
gatekeepers to like say come on in yeah
but what I see is somebody who who deals
with that by creating what you can in
the interim whether it's like making a
music video with Davy you know the 500
mile song even what our boy what's up
Davy Seamus - Davy looks good I kind of
like it on him it's endearing he looks
so creepy hood all right it looks super
creepy but you're always kind of you got
like these little hustles going all the
time yeah here's the thing that I and
it's great that you brought this up is
like you know you are in the sweet spot
you create your content you are the boss
you validate yourself every day with the
rock with the hand paddles on the ground
and I still have books with publishing
companies and there's you know there's
other kinds of things that are somewhat
analogous Oh fair enough but you travel
you your joys is what you do every day
right and to a great extent so is mine
like I do what I love for a living so I
almost never work and that's the truth
but a lot of it is based on other people
and
like when we talked about the power of
the poison of the no the no the no the
no problem is when you keep here and no
from these [ __ ] sometimes you
think that it has something to do with
you know
oh I'm less I'm less I'm less and that's
how you get crazy people out there crazy
actors who are miserable because they
seek validation from opinions of other
people if I don't get work then I am
nothing if these people don't get me a
job than I am nothing I get my
validation from going into the studio
and spending my money and working on a
song for six hours that feels great or
writing a poem or doing a podcast are
coming to do this with you like this
feels better and what I get the power
and the magic that I get from sharing
with you someone who I inspire who I am
inspired by and look up to is that I can
go into an audition right now be fully
prepared I care I care about my craft
I'll be memorized I'll be off-book
I'll make strong choices I'll go in I'll
do it I'll throw the sides away as soon
as I leave in the trash cans provided to
me right outside the door and I won't
think about it again right that that
ability to detach from the results of
your labors right because you know hey
man whatever happens is supposed to
happen but you know what later on today
or tomorrow I'm going back in the studio
like just moving what's the next
creative thing what's the next creative
thing and that feels great I mean that's
a wonderful way and I always tell people
when they're like what do i do what do i
do I go rule number one don't quit when
you think you're when you quit like just
go to bed and wake up the next day and
you'll be fine rule number one don't
quit no ii don't have a back-up plan
rule number three finish what you start
when you start it make sure that [ __ ] is
done it might be a piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
but you get it done and you learn how to
finish what you start that's a big deal
and then the create your own content and
find something that you love that has
nothing to do with how you make money
mmm find something else that validates
you whether it's relation like if it's
the relationship or you have kids or
like you I don't know you Poe go on the
weekends like
I don't know you skydive you do
something find something for me the
thing I love most in the world
is basketball I can't I'm not a
professional basketball player I'm in
the chiropractor every week as if I am a
professional basketball player but
that's the thing that I do for nothing
there's no reason to do it other than to
get better at it while simultaneously
declining athletically and learning how
to play an right man game and so it's
like if I make a three-pointer that wins
the game in a basketball game it's all
means up you have like a standing game
and like dudes you play with yeah the
whole thing three or four a week and
like if I make a game-winning shot it
feels better than booking an acting job
right be crazy I know it's weird that's
where I'm at right well I think like as
as you know this millennial you know
representation of multicultural creative
expression in Hollywood like you're like
you're you understand something that the
generation that precedes you fails to
fully embrace with a few exceptions
which is that on some level you kind of
you know override this lack of ability
to control your destiny that you do have
to be sort of entrepreneurial about your
career with these to the extent that you
can create these other projects right
and to be industrious and that in that
pursuit like whether it's an album or
writing songs or doing you know the like
the Freestyle stuff that you do or
getting up on stage like I see you doing
that stuff all the time yeah and it's
like as an actor when do you actually
get to do your craft you know in a
professional capacity like it's almost
never right
howdy as a creative person how do you
stoke that fire and remain creatively
engaged and you know to the creative
people that are listening to this I mean
your laundry list of like things to do
and not do I think is super instructive
but to be engaged creatively with
something that inspires you all the time
that doesn't require the yes-or-no of
somebody else I think that is crucial
you know it's I'll go through months
right like I went through it in the
month
be wary where I was like I'm gonna say
yes to anything like literally whatever
someone asks me to do I'm just gonna say
yes you should have known that matter
what I asked you to do some stuff
creatively so like now I'm in a theater
company because someone was like one
being my theater come really yes and
like I just was like let's just knock it
up a little bit right kick up some dust
and see what's up let's add let's just
add like we're getting a little too
sedentary we're a little stagnant like
let's do some new [ __ ] and like I'll do
that you know the other big thing is
like we talked about entitlement and the
dark side of that is that you think
people owe you anything
and you think that people should work
for you for free no I pay everyone that
I work with I pay them as much as I
possibly can without breaking like
without going broke people's time is
worth money and a lot of creative people
think that they need to have homie
discounts and free friend stuff is like
no no that's why you go oh yeah he said
he was gonna do it for free and he never
edited it it took six months to get to
edit mm-hm it's like yeah that guy's got
to eat conversely the person who agrees
to do stuff for free without valuing
their own time and creative input yeah
and I mean that's a different that like
sometimes it's good to do stuff for free
yes you are a little too entitled around
that but I try my best to in some way
value the work that people do with me
and and for me if that's the case and
then also like it's so basic but we
don't understand it's like don't be a
dick like how as a leader or as a
creative person can you communicate in a
loving way even when things aren't going
well like I'm trying to get this
producer to get the vocal into the beat
that it needs to go on and it's so
simple to me and there's a human being
out there who would go why the [ __ ]
can't you just get this right thank God
I'm not that that that dude well it's
just how I think I'm rambling now but
it's like how you communicate and things
like that yeah no I think that's
important how do you see Hollywood
changing in the wake of you know
everything that's happening with me too
and how is that spilling into the
conversation around race and
I would I mean I think they're totally
separate I think it's far the me to
thing is its own thing and I'm not
educated enough on it to speak on it I
think that it's obviously important to
have parity I think it's really
important to have equal pay and there
are much more there are many more people
who have who are smarter than me who can
talk about that in a more nuanced way
than I ever could school but in terms of
race in Hollywood it's still a black and
white town and I think it's okay
that it's a black and white town because
it used to just be a white town and but
there's still the trans community the
you know the gay community the Asian
community South Asian community Latinos
like who I don't know when we'll be a
part of the conversation but and maybe
we're getting there I mean you brought
up Kumail and you know I brought up Aziz
and rizz and Mindy you know we're
talking about four people out of how
many people are at the Oscars so it's
some slow going and I don't know when
we're gonna be seen as part of the
conversation we all obviously in this
country like we're not equal part we
can't be the and I don't want to compare
mm-hmm because that's silly it's not who
has it worse
or who has it better or that's the
problem is like each of our little
groups and in factions we go well we
have it hard this way and this is what's
tough for us and it's like then you just
compare and then you're just a dick like
that's not the point the point is to
just be like if you just silo yourself
into your particular camp and and kind
of you know descend into the part of
identity politics that doesn't work well
that you mean yeah that's the thing
that's where we are right now is there
so many sub categories and each sub
category has its own set of rules and
things
are off-limits and things that are
insulting and it's very tough makes it
tough to communicate very hard it's
really difficult so how can so all I can
do is reach out to young South Asians if
they want some advice or need mentoring
I'm here I'm available anyone can tell
you like if you reach out to me and I
think you're about your [ __ ] I will
respond like I'm open I'm I've worked
with and mentored several people I put
out my own work and I try and just be a
good example for who I can be and that's
all I can control and yeah I wish that
we were like there was more but then
like I'm also totally cool where I'm at
it's it's just a balance yeah but you
get to be part of that solution in that
conversation yeah it'd be so cool if
somebody like it'll be cool when I'm a
Jane I do to someone like when I Jay's
my og and I'll be somebody else's og and
to the hotel and he goes to be grandpa's
og and it'll be fun I think you already
are man yeah I'm somebody's grandpa I
think that's a good place to to end it
man if people if if if somebody is if is
that person what's the best place for
them to to get in touch with you is it
like Twitter or Instagram Twitter
Instagram at utk the ANC UT kth ein see
on Twitter and Instagram right I feel
like you could just go by one name speed
cars I've thought about it like oh sure
yeah you could totally pull that off I
wonder especially since your last names
too hard to say how about [ __ ] anyway
hahaha I might just change it at this
point it's like might as well mm-hmm how
do you feel good I feel good I'm like
now enjoy it I don't know man I don't
know if I can do it anything else you
want to talk about no I think we hit it
good yeah I think we did good thanks man
ah I love you brother legacy thank you
for coming here and sharing it's
powerful stuff and I'm excited for you
dude like I see your future just
unfolding in front of you and it's
inspiring and it's a tribute it really
is like it's just like
create physical real-world validation
manifestation of like what happens when
you live a sober life when you live the
principles when you give back when
you're in service all of that stuff it's
like this magnet you know where your
life just gets bigger you know and I'm
seeing that happen with you right now
and I couldn't be more psyched for you
thanks man so cool man so come back and
talk to me again sometime oh for sure
definitely
[Music]